[Música]
obrigado a todos
na mesma semana
Eu sempre vivo apesar da invasão
das falhas que haverá uma vida como
quer
[Música]
30 manilha fria
desde 2006
ela ganha meu tempo com dois no mesmo
tudo isso e eu tenho para você
Vamos lá
isto
o sol e brilho
o fim que aparece hoje em fita
e se o mar puro passar
nada nada
atrás
[Música]
seu amor
sim
não demore a pesquisar
[Música]
para
não está claro o que são
a beleza
de bs
[Música]
xavi aqui
no seu estado
quando você vê
e como estamos
e isso tem que ser sem contra sabadell
hoje é hora de autorizar o
cabeça para o seu rosto
responder
[Música]
você tem que aparecer
S
mais do que puro mais
[Música]
dá
a uva
[Música]
isto
Vamos lá
[Música]
quando
Oh
Vamos lá
[Música]
[Aplausos]
Te quero
S
quando
[Música]
muito complicado
[Aplausos]